[Aplausos]
corea del norte es tal vez el país más
hermético cerrado y aislado del planeta
un país que en 2018 parece vivir en 1960
[Música]
sin embargo amigos ahora toda esta
historia puede estar a punto de cambiar
aquí en visual político ya os contamos
en un pasado vídeo como el capitalismo
está llegando a corea del norte de la
mano de los mercados populares cómo se
está produciendo toda una revolución
emprendedora y como hoy más del 50% de
los norcoreanos viven gracias a la
economía privada sin embargo nos
quedaron sobre la mesa un par de
preguntas que piensa uno de los
gobiernos más totalitarios del planeta
sobre esta particular revolución
capitalista qué planes tiene y otra
cuestión muy pero que muy importante
indian 3 estaría dispuesto a invertir en
corea del norte atentos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no son los mejores momentos
el 12 de junio de 2018 se celebró en
singapur un encuentro histórico por
primera vez el presidente de los eeuu en
este caso donald trump se reunía con un
líder norcoreano
[Música]
el objetivo supuestamente desnuclearizar
corea del norte
el objetivo probablemente real bueno
además de hacerse un par de fotos que
oye nunca vienen mal recobrar el diálogo
enfriar la enorme tensión que se había
generado e impedir que corea del norte
continuará con un programa nuclear que
le podría haber llevado a tener
capacidad de ataque sobre los mismísimos
eeuu claro que espera un momento porque
una cosa es la teoría y otra la realidad
que puede ser un poquito diferente
atentos a las últimas novedades las
agencias de espionaje de eeuu corea del
norte está trabajando en nuevos misiles
el secretario de estado mike pompeo
reconoció durante un testimonio en el
senado que las fábricas norcoreanas
continúan produciendo material fisible
usado en la producción de armas
nucleares
[Música]
y es que a día de hoy tal y como ya os
contamos aquí en visual polític parece
un poquito difícil que el régimen de
pyongyang acepte al menos a corto plazo
desprenderse de todas sus armas
nucleares que al fin y al cabo son su
mejor seguro de vida pero claro eso no
quiere decir que no acepte hacer
concesiones para normalizar sus
relaciones con el resto del mundo y
terminar con las sanciones
internacionales porque veréis desde que
kim jong-un llegó al poder en el año
2011 ha tenido dos prioridades por un
lado si el desarrollo de la bomba
nuclear pero por otro algo bastante
menos tenebroso la reforma económica
sí aunque parezca difícil de creer
teniendo en cuenta tanto sus discursos
como sus acciones los cambios que está
impulsando el dictador norcoreano quiere
cambiar la mala situación económica del
país
copiando algunos de los cambios que han
protagonizado antes países como china o
vietnam
[Música]
y ojo porque una vez desarrolladas las
capacidades nucleares la prioridad
número uno de piel ya es avanzar en el
desarrollo económico y para lograrlo
necesitan poner fin a las sanciones
internacionales que están causando un
daño enorme si vamos a ver aunque
parezca difícil la situación en corea
del norte aún puede empeorar fijaos por
ejemplo lo que ha ocurrido con las
relaciones comerciales entre corea del
norte y latinoamérica entre las
sanciones y el hundimiento de venezuela
o uno de los pocos países aliados de
corea del norte en todo el mundo las
relaciones se han hundido
[Música]
pero claro cuando hablamos de corea del
norte y ve su economía hablamos
necesariamente de china el 80% de todo
el comercio norcoreano y de toda la
entrada de divisas se produce a través
del gigante asiático y lo que ha
ocurrido es que china lleva años
presionando a pyongyang para que de una
vez por todas ponga en marcha las
reformas y como estos cambios han ido
más lentos que una tortuga con reuma
pues el año pasado pekín decidió empezar
a aplicar las sanciones internacionales
fijaos esto es lo que ocurría en el mes
de agosto de 2017 si no imponen las
primeras sanciones a corea del norte en
plena crisis con eeuu tal y como os
podéis imaginar teniendo en cuenta la
enorme dependencia que corea del norte
tiene de china esto supone un desastre
tan solo en los seis primeros meses de
2008 las compras chinas de productos
norcoreanos se han desplomado más de un
90 por ciento y las exportaciones chinas
hacia corea del norte un 40% todo esto
claro en el mercado oficial luego tal y
como vimos aquí en otro vídeo está el
mercado paralelo el mercado negro pero
eso es otra historia el caso es que todo
esto ha causado que la producción
industrial y minera norcoreana estén
viviendo su peor momento en años
y si a todo esto le sumamos el
desastroso estado de las
infraestructuras con apagones continuos
de electricidad menos de 1000 kilómetros
de carreteras pavimentadas en todo el
país y trenes decrépitos que funcionan
en muchos casos a poco más de 20
kilómetros por hora está claro que el
país necesita urgentemente un cambio de
180 grados y sabéis que empiezan lo
saben
[Música]
fue victoria del norte convertirse en el
nuevo vietnam amigos en 1986 vietnam
puso en marcha la conocida como política
del doi moi un conjunto de reformas
económicas similares a las de herencia
opinen china que tenían la misión de
dejar a un lado el comunismo y poner en
marcha una economía de mercado
para ello se disolvieron las
cooperativas agrícolas se eliminaron los
controles de precios se permitió la
propiedad de la tierra y se pusieron en
marcha políticas para atraer la
inversión extranjera durante los
siguientes 30 años la economía de
vietnam creció a una media anual de casi
el 7%
hoy vietnam está transformándose a una
velocidad vertiginosa y sus
exportaciones son ya más grandes que las
de países como brasil o australia
pues precisamente la pasada cumbre
intercoreana de abril entre kim jong-un
y el presidente de corea del sur muniáin
el líder norcoreano manifestó su interés
en seguir el modelo de vietnam
precisamente en esta línea del gobierno
norcoreano aprobado en los últimos años
algunas medidas significativas ha
impulsado la creación de mercados
privados ha dado más autonomía a las
empresas públicas e incluso ha concedido
parcelas de tierra para su explotación
privada a los campesinos sin embargo a
pesar de todo esto hay dos preguntas que
necesitamos contestar quién diantres
estaría dispuesto a invertir en corea
del norte
y qué más está dispuesto a hacer el
gobierno de pyonyang atentos
quien invertiría en corea del norte
si nos preguntaran en qué países nos
gustaría hacer negocios probablemente
corea del norte sería una de nuestras
últimas opciones invertir en un país tan
totalitario donde el líder hace y
deshace a su antojo donde el gobierno
actúa con una enorme brutalidad y se
dedica a amenazar al resto del planeta
invertir en un país donde el estado de
derecho y la seguridad jurídica son pura
fantasía venga ya pues amigos lo cierto
es que no todo el mundo lo ve de esta
forma
[Música]
algunas de las compañías más grandes de
corea del sur como hyundai lote
corporation o samsung ya han montado
grupos de trabajo para investigar y
analizar oportunidades de negocio
potenciales en corea del norte y según
las encuestas las tres cuartas partes de
las empresas de corea del sur estarían
dispuestas a invertir en el norte si se
levantan las sanciones
hyundai por ejemplo se está preparando
ya para una pronta reapertura de la zona
industrial de kaesong una zona
industrial junto a la frontera con corea
del sur que fue creada en 2004 para
albergar empresas extranjeras
mayoritariamente surcoreanas y que llegó
a dar trabajo a más de 80.000
norcoreanos pero que en 2013 ante las
crecientes tensiones entre las dos
coreas fue cerrado por el gobierno de
pyongyang incluso recientemente jim
rogers uno de los inversores más
importantes y conocidos de todos los
tiempos se ha lamentado de que los eeuu
no le permitan invertir en corea del
norte
y ha hecho declaraciones como esta corea
va a ser ahora el país más excitante del
mundo kim jong-un no quiere una guerra
kim no es norcoreano fue educado en
suiza sabe que hay un mundo diferente
fuera de allí necesitan de todo
electricidad jabón manteles si tienes
cualquier tipo de pericia vas a hacer
una fortuna
jim rogers claro que un momento la
pregunta que nos podemos hacer es que él
y andrés ven en un país como corea del
norte pues fundamentalmente
oportunidades
[Música]
veréis me explico corea del norte tiene
una población relativamente joven muy
emprendedora y con bajísimos costes
laborales además eso no es todo según
parece el país podría ser muy pero que
muy rico en recursos naturales oro zinc
cobre tierras raras el valor estimado de
todos los recursos minerales es de más
de 6 billones de dólares
[Música]
y luego tal y como dice jim rogers el
país está por hacer necesita de todo y
por si eso fuera poco además se
encuentra en medio de dos potencias
económicas china y corea del sur fijaos
en la pasada cumbre intercoreana el
presidente de corea del sur le entregó a
kim jong-un un pendrive donde se
incluían un montón de inversiones que
corea del sur estaría dispuesta a
realizar
por ejemplo seúl estaría muy interesado
en construir ferrocarriles trans
coreanos que además de impulsar la
economía norcoreana le permitirían a
corea del sur exportar mercancías de
forma mucho más rápida a china y lo
mismo con carreteras oleoductos etcétera
etcétera
los planes serían mil millonarios
[Música]
claro que un momento porque no todo es
tan sencillo y el entusiasmo no es ni
mucho menos generalizado corea del norte
es una brutal dictadura la corrupción es
gigantesca y el gobierno puede hacer
literalmente lo que le dé la gana por
ejemplo expropiar te bueno pero es que
usted tenga cuidado con lo que me
responda porque me está diciendo que el
banco no está en venta pero yo se lo
puedo expropiar ya inmediatamente si
quiero
y aquí es donde se va a hacer el dinero
si usted puede averiguar cómo no ser
expropiado justin hastings profesor
asociado de la universidad de sydney
claro que en algunos casos un elevado
riesgo puede ser compensado con altas
rentabilidades pero luego por supuesto
está el tema de las sanciones
internacionales como consecuencia del
programa nuclear y hasta que no se
levanten cualquier cambio tendrá un
recorrido muy pero que muy corto ahora
bien es precisamente en este punto donde
china puede jugar un papel muy pero que
muy relevante veréis xi jinping el líder
chino ha conseguido lo que lleva años
buscando que pyongyang se ponga las
pilas lo que evidentemente podría ser un
gran negocio para las empresas chinas y
por eso lo que ahora quiere china es
fijaos
china ya pide que se levanten sanciones
contra corea del norte tras la cumbre en
singapur y no sólo eso
china está permitiendo el mercado negro
entre los dos países ha acelerado los
planes de desarrollo en la zona
fronteriza y ya están estudiando la
inminente apertura de zonas económicas
especiales en la frontera con corea del
norte y luego está el turismo que
precisamente es una de las grandes
prioridades del gobierno de kim jong-un
atentos
[Música]
corea del norte lugar de vacaciones me
parece que no os va a resultar nada
extraño la llegada de turistas chinos no
ha parado de crecer en los últimos años
y desde mayo de 2019 el número de
llegadas diarias se ha más que duplicado
vamos a operar al menos siete u ocho
rutas turísticas a corea del norte de
este año incluyendo un viaje de un día a
nanjo y un viaje de 4 a 5 días a
pyongyang que son y panmunjom changing
subdirector de una agencia de viajes
china y precisamente el turismo es una
de las grandes prioridades del gobierno
de pyonyang por varios motivos primero
para generar empleo recordad que este es
un sector muy intensivo en mano de obra
atraer a inversiones y conseguir
rápidamente divisas extranjeras
[Música]
por otro lado el turismo podría ayudar a
cambiar la imagen del régimen y la
verdad vamos a ver cambiar los desfiles
nucleares y la amenaza nuclear por
playas exóticas y cenas con marisco
sería algo bastante pero que bastante
bueno para los negocios por estos
motivos en 2014 el gobierno de corea del
norte creó la zona especial turística de
watson una zona económica especial donde
se permiten la inversión extranjera y
donde en principio el régimen permitirá
más libertades para desarrollar el
turismo si es la misma zona donde hasta
hace poco el ejército 100 sellos como
éste cosas de corea del norte
[Música]
el caso es que con el programa nuclear y
las sanciones los resultados han sido
muy pero que muy escasos sin embargo kim
jong-un quiere pisar el acelerador sin
ir más lejos en 2017 el gobierno de
corea del norte envió una delegación a
españa que como sabéis es una de las
mayores potencias turísticas del mundo
para conocer lugares como benidorm o
marina d'or aprender de ellos y tomar
ideas
tal cual como lo escucháis según parece
el objetivo que manejan en pyongyang es
conseguir atraer más de un millón de
turistas cada año en el corto plazo y de
5 a 10 millones en un futuro razonable
la pregunta es estar a kim jong-un
realmente dispuesto a llevar a cabo
todas las reformas que el país necesita
para que todos estos planes puedan
hacerse realidad amigos sólo el futuro
podrá contestar nos ha de esta pregunta
de momento lo que sí parece claro es que
estamos ante la mejor la mejor
oportunidad para dejar atrás la
pesadilla norcoreana que ojo no sólo ha
sido una amenaza para el resto del mundo
sino sobre todo un castigo de miedo y
represión una gran cárcel para los
propios norcoreanos pero ahora turno
para ti eres partidario de levantar las
sanciones contra corea del norte déjanos
tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta si te ha
resultado interesante el vídeo no
olvides darle like y si puedes te
agradeceremos un montón que nos eche una
mano en patrón un saludo y hasta la
próxima
bueno pues decir ustedes tengan cuidado
con lo que me responda para ver cuánto
me está diciendo que el banco no está en
venta pero sólo puede expropiar ya
inmediatamente si quiero
[Música]